اضطراب الهادئ لا يحدث عند استعراض الصين
صواريخها البالستيه فقط ولا يقف عند اسطول
البحريه الامريكي المهيب بل هي حملات
القرصنه الممنهجه التهديد الاخطر والاقرب
ربما لتفجير ازمه مستقبليه
بدات قصه الاختراق الصيني لاهم قاعده
امريكيه في غرب الهادئ جوان وللبنيه
التحتيه داخل الولايات المتحده باخذ حيز
كبير في الاعلام الغربي منذ ايام فولت
ايفون مجموعه القراصنه المدعومين من
الحكومه الصينيه والمعروفه بتخصصها في جمع
المعلومات كما تدعي لاستخبارات الامريكيه
في تقريرها كانت وراء الهجوم لم تكن تلك
المحاوله الاولى للمجموعه لكنها كانت
نوعيه وتصعيديه لحد كبير والغريب ان
مايكروسوفت هي من فجرت القصه ليتولى بعدها
ظهور مسؤولين من وكاله الامن القومي
والامن السيبراني والبحريه الامريكيه
للتاكيد على ان الخطر لا يزال قائما دون
ذكر اي تفاصيل غير ان معلومه واحده افادت
بان العمليه تتطابق مع طريقه معروفه
باختراق الشبكات تصل للحواف فقط لابقائها
غير مكتشفه لسنوات وبعدها تفعل في الوقت
المناسب
عمليه مماثله قادره على القضاء على
الشبكات واحداث خلل في الاليات العسكريه
وهو ما ذكره التحالف الاستخبارتي العيون
الخمس تشريف النفي الصيني للاتهام
الامريكي لم يكن مستغربا ووصف بانه حمله
تضليل جماعيه تقودها امريكا لخدمه اجندتها
الجيوسياسيه اما السر في اختيار
مايكروسوفت لنشر القصه فاعتبره محللون
دعوه مفتوحه لشركات القطاع الخاص لحمايه
الشبكات والبنيه التحتيه العمود الفقري
الحقيقي للامن القومي الامريكي كرم حناوي
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات